we read the story i think this story has
a little bit to do with and by the way
we appreciate you for being vulnerable
and emotional here on the
podcast
[Music]
you know new international version bible
for the guy is a gift so here's a story
from uh uh good man project women are
not choosing bad men
men are choosing to be bad okay i like
steve harvey i like him as a person as a
character but as a dating coach i don't
know i watched a clip of him from a last
youtube on youtube and on it a young
woman expressed she was struggling to
find a good man steve harvey solution
well why don't you stop dating bad ones
the advice was so brilliant i started
sharing the kind of wisdom with men when
they complained about their dating woes
with women oh she cheated on you well
why did she date a cheater oh the woman
you ask out won't date you maybe stop
asking out women who aren't attracted to
you somehow the men got angry about the
dating advice they found that it's kind
of dismissive and thoughtful thoughtless
off the guys i fell in love with other
guys i fell in love i don't regret
dating them and i probably would love
would fall in love with the similar man
the future i didn't date the abuse of
lie or the guy who didn't understand
sexual boundaries i did that anyways so
the moral of the story is the following
so it is is the idea of dating a bad guy
like man i'm attracted to these guys is
that what they're looking for and is
that what they marry um
from a pastor why don't you take the
lead first i'm not a pastor bro
pastor dory like this but uh i'll say
this so
bad women bad men right
we want what we want however there are
some key things that we've been
attracted to and these traits some of
these bad guys have
and let's be real here right there's not
really a lot of men today these guys are
just wake up go with the flow they're
not really being men so as a result most
masculine men are guys that are like bad
boys outlaws guys that are doing like
crazy stuff and let's get turned on by
that it's the truth no matter how you
look at it you can tell them hey you
know what this guy's good for you he's
going to take care of you now i want a
guy's going to have i'm have fun with
have a good lifestyle so as a result
we're not going to naturally go towards
those guys now regarding um
bad guys
i would say guys who they are and
they'll let you know up front so you're
choosing a bad guy
you literally know what you what you get
into but guess what their emotions what
they think is possible how they can
change the guy they'll give it a shot
and as a result they go into these bad
scenarios and then they say oh he hurt
me but you saw the red flags at the very
beginning but guess what he looks good
he's tall he's uh crazy i'll give it a
shot i might be able to change him
but you were saying about being a you
know a bad guy i mean isn't it easier to
be a bad guy than it is to be a good guy
i mean if you're a good guy you're going
to school you're working out you're
working on your your career and stuff
like that you know you're spending time
uh you know maybe if you're a single
father or something like that with your
kids i mean that is something that's
considered you know honorable and
something that you're doing but to be a
bad guy just be a jerk and you know
don't even have any thought process i
mean what do you think about that as far
as i mean adam you're single you can
comment on that
well the uh
what they're talking about these bad i
think there's three types of guys when
it comes to cheaters there's number one
serial cheaters
they just they don't
whether they're upfront about it whether
they're it's hidden whether they're like
look i'm a polygamist i'd like multiple
chicks or whether they're just like kind
of do it in secret so that's number one
that's the serial cheater then there's
the number two there's the opportunist
well look i wasn't planning on cheating
but i'm here at a
you know a business trip in vegas and
some chicks talking to me and it's like
you know what is it exactly whoops how
that you know
different area codes whatever it is you
know so that's an opportunist and then
there's the number third number three
person it's like i would never yeah i
would never and then that that person i
would never when they meet that
opportunity it's whether they will yeah
or they won't yeah so that's how i kind
of define most men but it's um
most men are in that number two category
they're not complete
scumbag cheaters you know liars and
they're not
100 i'll always be faithful the rest of
my life they're opportunists and if the
opportunity
meets and you know a woman and
the thing is is is that
so there's attractive guys then there's
arousing guys and the thing is is that a
lot of women are really focused on the
arousing guys especially when they're
younger and more attractive and they can
actually negotiate for these higher
status men that are actually arousing
because the thing is is that as women
make more money and become more
successful and have their own career
they don't necessarily care about
provisioning as much especially when
they're younger and more attractive it's
like okay does this guy do it for me
does he arouse me does he do it for me
like mentally and unfortunately the
things that make you arousing to a woman
a lot of the times also are terrible
traits to have when it comes to a
long-term relationship you know you're
not being non-committal you're not
showing her that much attention you're
treating her like crap you're putting
her like on the six on your party list
everything else and these things make
you arousing to women because women
respect men that don't necessarily chase
their validation and the woman has to
chase their validation and that's for
you as a guy that's exactly where you
want to be you always want the girl
chasing you feeling like she's getting
the best deal because that's what's
going to keep her in check that's going
to
give her keep her giving you the best um
treatment not cheating on you not doing
stupid [ __ ] because she's like damn okay
i'm fighting to get this guy i know he
has other girls this is what arouses me
about from a like a relationship
standpoint it's terrible but here's the
problem women are slaves to their
emotions if a guy makes her feel a
certain way
right and good takes her through the
emotional rollercoaster she's going to
go ahead and side with that guy so
the thing is is that a lot of girls
i'm just going to be honest don't like
to take accountability for the type of
men that they pick and i tell girls all
the time if you're going to date a man
that's attractive tall has money
whatever be prepared to share him but a
lot of sexually i mean and a lot of
girls don't want to hear that no i want
him to be monogamous to me men ain't
[ __ ] blah blah blah why can't he just be
loyal men and male loyalty and female
loyalty is completely different male
loyalty is he going to protect you in
times of danger is he going to provision
for you're going to take care of you
female loyalty is sexual fidelity but
again we're going back to how women
think men and women are the same they
think well you should also exercise
sexual fidelity uh no men and women are
different for a guy right we show our
loyalty differently than you do you show
your fidelity by not [ __ ] other
people i show my fidelity by being
willing to die and protect you right but
a lot of girls don't understand and they
don't like it and i've always said it as
a man goes up and up the socioeconomic
totem pole the rare the more rare catch
he is the higher the likelihood he's
going to cheat on you and it's kind of
this this delicate balance that girls
don't understand is a catch-22 you are
going to become a slave to the very man
that you want but you don't have any
negotiating power and that's another
thing women forget too is that as you go
up the totem pole as a woman you lose
leverage you're not able to control this
guy the same way but here's the problem
that's women arose arise by aroused by
they want a guy that they can't control
but then they get mad when they don't
have the control but then they come and
run it back to him that's why toxic guys
do so well because women can't
necessarily control them but that guy
can control our emotions but men also
have
some sort of epiphany moment like let's
take a look at the george clooney's of
the world or even the leonardo dicaprio
or the derek jeters they're
you know there's there's there's
baseball diamonds you know you've seen
this thing the derrick j derek jeter's
hit list and it's like
so and so in left field and halle berry
in center field and
uh you know the name after name after
name model after model but at some point
even a man will say look
i've had enough yeah but here's the
thing they'll say i've had enough and
they'll get a girl and take her
seriously for a while they'll be their
main chick but i've always said it high
status men nine out of ten times are
gonna [ __ ] other girls regardless like a
lot of the times are there guys are
gonna be monogamous for sure but out of
possibility if i lined up a hundred
high-value men that have options
whatever athlete's slept whatever it may
be i would argue probably 95 of them are
going to go out and smash other chicks
on the side these are they're giving our
computers uh women yeah yeah i mean it's
a who's who
and i think women don't understand and
or like that when i tell them that if
you're going to have a high value man
you're not going to have them to
yourself he's going to exercise options
to have sex with other girls so just
make peace with it in your mind that you
are going to
like it's great you have this high
status guy that's that's your boyfriend
but he's also going to have sex with
other girls and that's not that big a
deal honestly like sex is not that big a
deal for men it's like taking a piss
patrick
yeah i know so he's telling the story
it made me think about something we were
hanging out with uh seattle supersonic
players okay
years ago i'm talking i'm 25 years old
and they're telling stories
and
he says let me tell you what the life is
like what's the life like you know sean
kemp
gary payton let me tell you what the
life is like you go through here's this
city here's that city here's this city
here's this city here's that city and i
said so i got a question for you what's
that
why do nba players get married
why if you're a star what are you
getting married for
if if you're a hollywood star what are
you getting married for in your 20s
if you're a
actor actress what are you doing getting
if you're a star and you got limelight
on you
the idea of you getting married man
again this is my opinion that number
needs to probably start with a four
not even a two not even a three it's
probably more closer to four when we
were in the military like why are you
getting married in the military it's not
a good idea to get married in the
military why you gotta go deploy for 18
months yep what do you think you're
doing you're gonna come back with a
popeye forearm on this side like oh look
at
so what do you what does that happen 18
months like so don't get married in the
military three deployments oh yeah three
deployments what do you think happens in
a situation like that i think you got a
a
you gotta have a system for yourself as
you get bigger
uh one of the best things i um
look i've been married twelve and a half
years shoot you look at my instagram
it's as if
being married is a bigger target and
being single you know being married it's
more interest because can i break you
can i do this there's a target for that
right for sure and your supporting cast
is number one not saying what the third
guy says because you're a bigger like
that guy right there with the form
so so but this is what i was going to
tell you is the supporting cast here's
how our supporting cast works i read a
book one time from billy graham this is
back in the days in 60s 70s 80s when all
these pastors having stories with girls
left and right and he's like wait a
minute what the hell are you guys doing
so billy graham said listen when we
travel
we share rooms he says i used to do with
one of our guys he says now when i
travel we have to be in a room with
three of us
you're like why would you do three why
not just have a body he says because
when it's just you and a friend you can
convince your friend listen no one's
gonna know yeah he says but when he's
three of you one is gonna say no guys we
can't yeah yeah yeah there'll be one
voice of reason yeah he says one time
they went into hotel room he says a girl
was waiting in a room half naked he says
we just ran out
he said we left it or we just ran out
because you know that's how stories are
written so you got to be careful
nowadays there's a target on everybody
and the more you said you can be
post right it's just
clearly satirical here i sent him
celibate yo you would not believe his
response i got on instagram yo they were
like really i'm gonna challenge i'm
gonna break that tonight
yo dude girls are going crazy and i was
like yeah imagine if you were married
bro
how much target you are like you said
earlier mm-hmm it's crazy bro girls get
mad but i always say like having other
women makes you more attractive there's
a reason why women want to be in a vip
with a rapper when he has a bunch of
other chicks there why are you going a
music video set like you see girls have
different shapes colors and sizes like
men like variety it's been that way
since the beginning of time and even if
a guy has a main girl he's going to want
to have you know something different
every now and then now do most guys do
are all guys going to be able to enact
on it no probably not but if you give a
guy i always say you take the most loyal
guy give him two million dollars a
[ __ ] blue check on instagram a
lamborghini in a mansion for a couple
weeks he's probably gonna start smashing
some chicks
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]